>> Throughout this course, we've discussed human thought and behaviors processes
that are driven by both nature and nurture. And this lesson on mental illness
epitomizes the dynamic interplay between the two.
>> That's right. And as we said throughout the course, we are like little chemical
factories, making chemicals that help us live successfully in our environment.
But as you've seen from this lesson, sometimes there can be a tragic disconnect
between our individual nature and nurture experience which can result in mental
illness.
>> Although this lesson is sobering, we really hope that it shows you to be
thankful the times that you're experiencing positive mental health.
>> That's right, and remember that it's not unusual for us to experience highs and
lows throughout our life, periods of anxiety or depression. But it's when we
don't have these experiences that we should be fortunate and thankful for our
good mental health.
>> Now that you've completed this lesson, we hope that you're a more educated
person in the terms of mental health literacy and that any negative stereotype
or stigma that you may have once had are now diminished or completely removed.
>> We as humans are unique and fascinating creatures and it's not uncommon for us
to experience difficulties in the sometimes challenging world. However, when
those difficulties manifest themselves through mental illness, that can be
challenging in and of itself. However, as we'll see in the next lesson, there
are a variety of techniques that can help reduce the symptoms of mental illness
such that people can live fulfilling, meaningful, adventurous, and proud lives.
There's absolutely no shame in mental illness. And in our next lesson, we're
going to learn about the treatments for mental disorders.